I have to show this picture cuz I think
this is the most Canadian thing I've
ever seen this is a photo from your
childhood so those are definitely ice
skates and living room so it's either is
this Christmas or is it just like a
Tuesday like what's what's happening I'm
not that's not me wearing the leg
warmers that's my sister but they were
yours she borrowed them from you we get
it no that is I dude I am so Canadian
are you kidding me I love it I'm that
was like and I remember how oh are you
kidding me how excited I was to get that
like anything I'm a huge van Canucks fan
yeah they're called the Canucks yeah we
and you know okay okay but um anything
hockey I mean like I was I would die for
that's a vicious sport they get very
angry no they are missing teeth it's a
lot of I feel like it is actually it's
very redneck now that I think about it
it's very where I'm from I feel like I
feel like it it has such a code you know
what I really love about the game what
the humility of the game you know like
in basketball they score and then they
do do like celebrations and stuff and
football there's a whole they set up
celebrations they get to the end zone
hockey is like the better you are the
the greater you are the less celebrate
you score and you don't put your hand up
you're that
[Music]
[Applause]
cool thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home